xenoblade chronicles impressive scale
has always been a selling point for the
series nintendo's traditionally
underpowered hardware has never stopped
the appropriately named developer
monolith soft from creating massive
worlds and based on what i've played so
far xenoblade chronicles 3 is no
different while the early hours are
railroaded with cut scenes tutorials and
linear areas when the game opens up it
really opens up
[Music]
xenoblade chronicles 3 is oddly enough
the fourth game in the xenoblade
chronicles series all of which are
loosely tied to the long-running sci-fi
fantasy xeno franchise as monolithsoft's
director tatsuya takahashi put it in an
interview with time in 2015 the xeno
name really just exists to make it clear
that these are tetsuya takahashi
productions all that to say you don't
really need to play xenoblade chronicles
1 2 or x in order to understand what's
going on in xenoblade chronicles 3.
without getting into spoilers there are
nods to the other games but newcomers
should have no issues jumping into three
it has a new cast of characters a fresh
setting and a new story while you may
not need an encyclopedic knowledge of
the franchise 3 still has its fair share
of fantasy rpg mumbo jumbo flame clocks
ether channels not bonds offsears life
terms oroboros forms and so on while
fans of the series have come to expect
that kind of jargon a newcomer's
tolerance may vary the short of it is
that you play as noah a sword-wielding
flutist called an offsear who uses his
instrument to send off fallen soldiers
to the great beyond
[Music]
[Music]
noah is accompanied by lands uni and
momba together they are a special forces
unit tasked with keeping noah safe as he
attends to his mission but things go
sideways as they do and noah and team
are sent off on a globe trotting
adventure there's a lot to love in the
xenoblade franchise but the setting has
always been a highlight for me i feel
like a tiny speck in a massive dynamic
world while i have yet to come across an
area as awe-inspiring as the bionis leg
from xenoblade chronicles 1 or the
kingdom of uriah from xenoblade
chronicles 2 the first two major areas
i've been to are colorful distinct and
sprawling there's also a lot to do in
these open areas quests are scattered
around the landscape challenging
optional bosses called unique monsters
guard key locations and occasionally you
might come across enemies battling it
out amongst themselves in these
situations before the battle begins you
are given the option to pick a side the
side you pick determines your reward
unfortunately in the early hours you can
only join one faction during these
fights but i imagine that mechanic will
open up later in the story now i don't
want to dwell on story specifics for too
long but it's safe to say that it has
its hooks in me the voice acting is
better across the board the cutscenes
are flashier and more frequent and so
far the characters are intriguing
you nothing more
obviously it's going to take some time
to get a better understanding of who
these characters really are but so far
no one really fits into your typical
jrpg archetype except for tion aka
walmart joker who seems a little stilted
and standoffish thus far there you have
it
i sincerely hope for your safe return
it's hard to say whether or not the
story can hold onto this momentum but
i'm excited to continue my journey
nonetheless partly thanks to the combat
xenoblade chronicles 3 like its
predecessors features an mmo combat
style party members are divided into
three main classes attackers defenders
healers and then into various subclasses
equipped with different weapons and
abilities attackers are essentially dps
defenders are tanks and healers are
support auto attacks and timers offset
arc cooldowns which can be comboed
across multiple party members for
devastating effects better yet unlike
the previous games xenoblade chronicles
3 lets you swap characters mid battle
this means you can manually start and
finish combos across multiple members
without having to wait for them to use a
specific art this feels like it could be
a game changer especially during some of
the longer boss fights
[Music]
this is only the tip of the iceberg
though i fully expect the combat to ramp
up significantly as it did in previous
games one of the most notable additions
to combat is the robust class system as
demonstrated in the xenoblade chronicles
3 direct players can change a party
member's subclass to further customize
their moves and battle styles
unfortunately the preview session didn't
allow me to experiment with this feature
as much as i would have liked but so far
it seems like a pretty interesting idea
that could add even more depth and
strategy to the combat xenoblade
chronicles 3 also adds the oroboros
ability basically two compatible party
members fuse into a giant mech-like
creature you can activate oroboros with
the touch of a button and they play like
your typical party members except their
arts don't have cooldowns eventually
they overheat and kick out both party
members i've only used this ability once
so far so it's hard to gauge whether or
not it adds anything meaningful to the
combat based on what we saw from the
direct it seems like there is still a
lot more to uncover about the oroboros
forms so hopefully the new mechanic will
add more strategic depth as i progress
[Music]
thankfully xenoblade chronicles 3 has a
robust tip menu that's accessible right
from the get-go and automatically
updates as you progress a a notable
improvement over the last game's
tutorial tips menu which had to be
purchased from an in-game vendor
additionally 3 has a series of
repeatable drills for players who might
need a little extra combat guidance
[Music]
the in-game menus are also a marked
improvement over xenoblade chronicles 2.
like the previous games you will spend a
lot of time in menus managing move sets
loadouts and accessories this time
flipping between menus and swapping
between settings feels a lot snappier
some menus that were once buried in
other menus are far more accessible it's
hard to say whether or not the menu ui
will buckle as more features and
mechanics are introduced but as of now
it feels a lot more approachable than
two's menus however i do worry about the
ever-present limitations of the nintendo
switch hardware with a game like
xenoblade chronicles 3. i didn't run
into any major issues during my time but
the low frame rate and resolution
definitely took some getting used to
nintendo hasn't announced the exact
frame rate and resolution for xenoblade
chronicles 3 and we lack the tools to
properly test it but considering
xenoblade chronicles definitive edition
and xenoblade chronicles 2 both hit 30.
i'd imagine it's the same for three
fortunately though the frame rate was
consistent whether or not it holds its
consistency over the course of the game
remains to be seen for some like myself
these issues are easy to overlook but
worth noting for the more text sensitive
crowd especially if you might be playing
on a 4k monitor or tv overall i am
curiously optimistic for xenoblade
chronicles 3. so far monolith soft has
laid out all the ingredients for a
memorable jrpg and now it's just a
matter of seeing what they've managed to
cook up the big question i have now as i
do with most jrpgs of this scale is
whether or not it can keep me hooked for
the entire run time for an answer to
that question and more keep an eye out
for my full review of xenoblade
chronicles 3 in the coming weeks in the
meantime you can find me on twitter at
jacob deck if you have any burning
questions about my time with xenoblade
chronicles 3.